well it was uh it was a pretty active
night and
if i'm the nfl i don't want to see my
ratings on the game
even though you know aaron rodgers was
playing he was playing the
san francisco 49ers second pre-season
game
second half lineup and uh
i i don't i don't know what in the world
you judge out of that
you know what you judge out of that for
the for the uh
for the packers mike you know basically
that
they had had two clunkers you know in in
the last three weeks
and so they go into this game on the
road in a place that's really been their
bugaboo
and they had to kill him and they did
and
and they they played well defensively
which they should have um you know
especially without trent williams on
that left side and it was a disaster
there all night
but i say what i said about the ratings
because
you know is could anybody not watch this
incredible drama you know whether we all
know what way the game is going to end
the political game i you know i don't
know i didn't watch a lot of football
last night i
i must confess i don't know what you're
talking about
what are you talking about i don't know
what you're talking about
uh at one point it was 31-3
on fox uh yeah elsewhere a 28 to three
lead was evaporating
thanks to our friends in georgia but uh
we're not here to talk about any of that
as the tide
inevitably turns in in the direction
uh that uh you know and and let me just
say this for anyone out there who thinks
there's and
you know what we've avoided this all
week but i just need to say this for
anyone out there that thinks there's any
funny business going on
the problem is there are multiple states
where they refuse to count the mail-in
votes until after the election ended
that's why we are
where we are in some of these states in
florida
got to give them credit they did all
their counting ahead of time
they did all their counting the mail-in
ballots ahead of time so we had a result
from florida on election night if all
these other states had done the same
damn thing
this would have there wouldn't this
would have been over drama we would have
known tuesday night exactly what was
going on and everyone could have enjoyed
the green bay packers versus the san
francisco 29ers
last night because roughly half the team
was unavailable
for san francisco and company and look
peter i look at last night's game
big takeaway the packers got their act
together in california
they were 14-1 last year
everywhere but california
in california they were owen three last
year
they just couldn't get it together they
lacked energy when they lost to the
chargers in la last november even though
packers fans overran that soccer stadium
where the chargers used to play
zadaria smith told us after the packers
lost to the san francisco 49ers in the
nfc championship game
the team wasn't ready to play and i
wasn't ready to play
so we've seen this issue with the
packers not getting themselves in the
right mindset to go out there and do
what they can do
and on sunday aaron rodgers lamented the
fact after they lost to the vikings they
didn't have the proper energy so
to their credit they went out there they
took care of business and maybe all the
uncertainty
and the questions and are we going to
play right maybe that distracted them
from getting lackadaisical
but and and maybe it's because they were
playing a bad collection of players
but for the packers at least they got
back on the horse
after getting kicked off of it on sunday
and that's very good news for them
because i was concerned
for the packers that they were going to
find a way to blow this if they weren't
able to get the lawnmower started
i would disagree this that this had
anything to do with california
this had something to do with
the san francisco 49ers not having
garoppolo kittle bosa sherman
and about 20 other guys as you
referenced that's why
that's why what happened last night
happened it had no they could have
played this game in antarctica and who
it would not have mattered and look i
i'd have to go back and look at that
charger game last year
it was a weird game i don't know what
happened in that game
but those two san francisco games
the packers gave up 37 in each game
could do nothing offensively because
aaron rodgers
mostly was running for his life and
that's why
these things happen they don't happen
because of some sort of
california jinx or anything like that
they happen because of the players on
the field
and last night the san francisco 49ers
were a week two second half pre-season
game
team that's that's who played in the
game
so if aaron rodgers can't beat them
soundly
and without that garbage time touchdown
with four seconds to go
i mean it would have it certainly looked
more respectable than it was but
the packers just cleaned their clocks
and rightfully so
well but i disagree peter there is an
issue in the packers organization that
rears its head at the worst possible
times last year it just happened to be
on the road
three times in california when they
played the chargers i think they went
out there on friday
and aaron rodgers when you read between
the lines of what he said after the game
i think that he believes
you know if they had the night off on
friday his guys went out and had a
little bit too good of a time
they didn't have enough rest that was
the specific thing he said
about the game against the chargers
where they stepped into a pothole and
lost to a team they shouldn't have lost
to
but there is that issue that pops up
from time to time and i agree with you
last night
against the 49ers it wasn't going to
happen now
if they had found themselves in a game
who knows that's one of the things about
the packers and one thing sims always
says and i give him credit for this
if the packers get a lead now it didn't
help against the tampa bay buccaneers
when they got a 10-point lead but
typically if the packers get a lead it's
a different vibe
if they're in a grinded out game and the
running game is still an option for the
team that they're playing
that's when the packers sometimes find
themselves in a bad spot but last night
they held off what felt like an early
attempt by the 49ers to keep it
interesting
packers scored on the first drive 49ers
were in position to score and match it
settled for a field goal instead and
that allowed
the opening for the packers to turn it
into i think it was 21-3 by the time
halftime rolled around
so you give them that 21-3 lead this
packers team isn't going to blow it
and you know they never took their foot
off the gas there was a point
last night in the fourth quarter where
i'm thinking why is aaron jones
still playing why is devonta adams still
playing
why is aaron rodgers why is aaron
rodgers still playing
yeah yeah and and i think that i think
that
that uh part of it is you know what guys
if you go out there and you bust your
asses you build a lead we're gonna let
you stay in and have a little bit of fun
here that's your reward
for building this lead it's working
tonight and you get to enjoy that
feeling and maybe you're gonna strive
to have that feeling more often
yeah and plus i think this i it had had
had they put rogers in for the last two
drive i mean the last drive was four
seconds but
had they put had they put rogers in with
whatever four minutes to go i would have
said that
you know this is malpractice but
look they took rogers out maybe one
series too late
but again that's that's a that's a a
page
four story you know the main story is
that the packers
had to play well they had to get their
offense purring again and look sometimes
it's good
to take advantage i mean i remember i i
we may have talked about this on this
show one time
one time i asked bill parcells back when
i covered the giants in the 80s
i said well you know you didn't have
george adams you didn't have leonard
marshall
you didn't have carl banks and blah blah
blah blah and parcel says hey
give me your media guide you got a media
guy so in those days when everybody had
a media guide and you looked at it 10
times a day
he flips to the back where there are
records okay year by year records
and he goes down each one he said hey
you see this peter he said
wlw
ll and and i said what do you mean he
goes
nobody cares back in 1964
i can look back the giants lost this
game it doesn't say the giants lost this
game
and why a tittle and tucker frederiksen
weren't playing
you know they just lost this game and
so i think at the end of the day what
you want to know
if you're a fan of the green bay packers
is did my team show up
did we take care of business did we get
back on track
to to leave the chicago bears at some
point this year
in the dust and win this division yes
yes yes
well and you make a good point so years
from now when we are all
carrying around embedded computer chips
and all we have to do is blink our eyes
and pull up the san francisco
49ers schedule from the year 2020 and we
see the loss
on thursday november 5.
the asterisk will not be there should it
be there
specifically should the game have been
played
given the outbreak not outbreak because
it's a different
thing than an outbreak it's one guy test
positive
several other guys deemed to be in
sufficiently close contact
that they aren't allowed to play even if
they
never get the virus should there have
been
a delay of the game to sunday
to monday to tuesday to give the 49ers a
chance to
adjust and to give the guys who may
never develop the virus
a chance to come back and play
i'll say this just in terms of um
you know what everybody is going to
suspect
anyway but that
is a 60 million dollar football game
last night and if you don't play the
game
and you play the game at a later day
let's just say um you have to ask
yourself
what does the nfl have to give fox to
make up for it
okay that's the first question and don't
anybody think that that doesn't matter
it matters okay but i think the second
question is roger goodell has said this
time and again
and he said it internally mostly but he
also said it to me the week before the
season started
and that is this there's a reason why we
had free agency
on time there's a reason why we had the
draft
on time because there is no
guarantee that it's going to be better a
week from now or four or five days from
now
and so that is the biggest issue and
as everybody now mentally believes
categorically there's going to be a week
18.
and i think there's a pretty good chance
there's going to be a week 18.
but the reason why i don't think it's
guaranteed i think
last night's game told everybody in the
league
we're not kidding around here we're not
giving you a hall pass
okay you better get all your players in
line
last night was a little bit just a
little bit punitive
you know against the san francisco 49ers
and you can read something into this
just like you can read something into
uh what has happened this year with the
raiders you know
if you don't take care of all of your
protocols
every single one and you
suffer because of it don't look at us to
come and save your bacon
that's what last night said to me in
part
and we'll be talking about what the
league ultimately did to the raiders
coming up in the program but
you know i agree with you peter on both
counts number one
the ball's on the t you better kick it
because by sunday or monday the ball may
not be on the t
the situation with the 49ers could get
worse where you can't play the game at
all this week and then
packers at 49ers becomes the first game
of the 18th week of the regular season
so i think there's an urgency and i
think we first really
saw it or at least noticed it with the
buccaneers raiders game a few weeks ago
where the raiders didn't have their
starting offensive line at least four of
them until the day before the game they
were woefully unprepared but so what
let's play because if we move into
monday or tuesday and frankly that would
have been
a boon for the networks whoever would
have televised that game
it fell into that black hole of regional
405 pm eastern broadcast people didn't
get to enjoy that game but if you delay
it
something could go wrong you don't get
the game in and then you're screwed so
there's an
urgency to play the games when the games
are ready to be played
and there also is that subtle hey if you
took better care of your business
you wouldn't have this issue i have an
issue with that though
because if you're gonna have these guys
in a situation where they all
scatter at the end of the work day they
all
punch out and they go their separate
ways
up to 170 separate ways at a time when
the pandemic if you haven't noticed and
i know it was supposed to go away on
november four
it hasn't we had a new record of cases
for the second straight day six
figures for the second straight day of
new cases so
the virus is out there and
look i know the message to
all players and coaches and essential
personnel is basically go home
and get yourself into a hermetically
sealed room and don't come out until the
next morning
but it's getting harder and harder to
not catch it that's my point
and i don't know that it's fair to have
this punitive element where
one guy gets it and anybody that he
happened to be in contact with during
that doughnut hole period of sample
collection
and positive test result gets knocked
out even if they never
get it that to me
it's hard to reconcile peter with the
fact that the virus is winning
and the nfl continues every night to
send everybody out
into the covet 19 wilderness
well i i talked to one club executive
this week mike who told me
that they have really tried
to urge their players because you know
what happens
with with with players on game weekends
especially players
whose families come in for game weekends
you know you've got you've got wealthy
guys their families come in
from different parts of the country they
come in and they many of them
stay in the homes of the players
and this one executive said we have
appealed to the players
please please have your family members
stay at hotels and
i know of at least one case where the
team believes
that a player contracted covid from a
visiting family
on a weekend trip so that to me
is almost next level quite honestly mike
i honestly think that players i don't
know that you can
ban them from having families stay with
them over the weekend
but it only makes sense why
in the world would you allow people
let's say four or five people to come
into your home
from wherever they have come from and
you have no idea
they certainly haven't been taking tests
they probably haven't been taking tests
they just come in and stay in your house
so those are the kind of things that to
me
are next level and if i'm dr sills
i'm paying attention to those things but
one other thing about what you said mike
that i believe
fervently you know you saw it with the
san francisco 49ers and i understand
how it's unfair for people who have been
in close contact
with a specific player to have to test
multiple times
to be able to come back into the womb of
the family i get it
but that's just part of the whole deal
what would you say if let's say for the
sake of argument
that those players with the 49ers didn't
uh you know sequester themselves and
didn't go away
but came right back into the team and
were in the locker room last night
and two days from now uh you know
brandon iowa tes
you know test positive and he's been
around all these guys for four or five
days
you'd say that's totally irresponsible
that's why they have to do this at least
in my opinion
and there is a potential element of
wrongdoing here the nfl and the nflpa
investigating i'm told the 49ers for
potential protocol violations as it
relates to kendrick bourne and possibly
being
in too close of contact with others not
wearing the mask in the building the
things the nfl
has typically been investigating and
finding
these issues and shame on the teams that
haven't figured it out
by now that you better comply if you
want to have a chance at contending if
you want to
have a chance at winning games if you
don't have a shot at the super bowl
you better comply and that's why i think
the one team peter
that we're never going to hear an issue
about
that from this year as a pittsburgh
steelers because you're going to have to
answer to mike tomlin if you screw
around and that's strong enough maybe
it's not strong enough in any other city
it's strong enough in pittsburgh
to keep the steelers in line at all
times all right back to the
packers 49ers game devonta adams who
somehow did not make the top 10 list of
receivers is crafted by
one christopher david sims and devonte
adams
reacted to that at the time here's
devonte
adams from last night not just putting
himself
in the top ten putting himself on the
top of the mountain
do you think you're at the point where
you can say you're the best wide
receiver in the nfl
do you think that's fair to say uh yeah
i think that's fair to say
i think that's not uh that's not being
conceded that's just being confident i
think um
you know obviously what i've what i've
done and um what i'm going to continue
to do is going to prove that
um to anybody who who isn't on board
with that but i truly believe that uh
just based off of the work that i put in
um you know the connection that i have
between my quarterback
yeah he just he's so talented he can do
it all
hand himself the right way he's just a
joy to play with
a special guy
now look i think dk metcalf may have an
argument to make but peter would devonte
adams had been saying what he was saying
last night if he had to face richard
sherman last night
it's a good question mike i mean you
know the way i look at devonta adams
right now is that he is in a great place
in time and he's doing everything he
needs to do
to justify people if people would say
he's the best
what i think this illustrates devonte
adams great play especially over the
last month
and aaron rodgers approach and aaron
rodgers attitude and i really want to
get to that mike it's
very important but what i want to say
about davonte adams is we are in a
in the golden age of wide receivers
right now because remember last year
toward the end of the year there was
nobody better than michael thomas
and now thomas is out for six weeks with
an injury
and so all of a sudden now dk metcalf
and davonte adams are the best
and for a while stefan diggs early in
the season was the best
and that is great for football number
one but devonta adams in my opinion
aaron rodgers is right he does so many
things great he's great on the sideline
routes
he's great on the nine rounds he's great
downfield
he's great in the middle of the field
he's the perfect uh receiver for aaron
rodgers and let me say one thing about
aaron rodgers
this has not been said enough everybody
talks about his ability and
the touch on his passes and what a great
year he's having
you know one of the reasons in my
opinion why he's having a great year
because aaron rodgers has left all of
the distracting
crap at the door when he walks into work
every day this is the thing that
someone in green bay told me that he
said aaron rodgers
is like the welcome wagon host you know
that
you know when he was a little bit you
know last year the year before
snarky and you know angry young man at
times and all that
he's not now and i think in the off
season he
basically had a talk with himself and
said hey listen
i have got to approach my job with
optimism
and to go in and lead my team no matter
who is around me and that to me is what
we're seeing in aaron rodgers his
approach to the game
has been abs absolutely perfect does he
[ __ ] at the trading deadline
when they don't get will fuller maybe he
says something
very internally but you'll never hear it
and that to me
is a sign that aaron rodgers has become
even a better
leader on this team right now than he
was a year ago or two years ago
oh when he was asked on sunday about
whether or not the packers should make a
move at receiver he began with that rise
smile
and started down the old path that he
would have gone down where the not so
hidden messages
come through his words and then within
about five seconds he got it together
and he said that's not my role
so i think you're right he is winning a
battle
with himself because he understands a
certain demeanor a certain approach
that's necessary
to get the most out of his talents you
saw the stats up there on the screen
he's completing nearly 75 of his passes
28 touchdown passes two interceptions
he's having a spectacular year
he's going to be in the mvp conversation
and we'll see how he feels after the
season
or after next season if he does it again
because jordan love continues to loom
and any hard feelings see no matter what
the packers say and do
to genuflect to kiss the ring to kiss
the butt
of aaron rodgers based on what he's
doing this year
they put him through something in late
april
that's never going to go away everything
that they do now
great it's fine it's appropriate praise
aaron rodgers you should
it doesn't erase the memory of the
thing that he saw during the draft that
caused him to go pour himself four
fingers of tequila
and sip slowly while he's stewed that's
not going away
so my point to you is this peter there's
an end to all this where it could turn
again for now he's doing everything that
he has to do to have a great season
and good for him and good for the
packers and think about devonta adams
and you're right about it's a golden age
of receivers simple reason for it on the
surface
with all of these quarterbacks who are
throwing the ball
at every level of the game now and the
seven on
sevens are happening all the time well
somebody's catching those passes so as
these young quarterbacks develop
all these guys who are there as the
other end
of the connection they're developing too
and i think the magic ingredient to a
great receiver peter is to not be a
first round draft pick now that's hardly
universal
but devonte adams second round pick
michael thomas
second round pick and dk metcalf said it
himself yesterday it was a blessing in
disguise
that i was a second round pick because
it gave me an even larger chip on my
shoulder
it caused me not to take my position
here for granted
and to bust my butt and be the best
player i can be
and when you waltz onto the red carpet
at the draft and you're one of the top
10 players taken
you got to find a different way to
motivate yourself and i'm not saying it
disqualifies a first round pick
at receiver from being great but man
some of the best guys in the game right
now
were not taken in round one
mike let me get back to aaron rodgers
and say one more thing but you're
absolutely right the
depth at wide receiver in these drafts
is incredible
andy dalton told me six or seven years
ago when i asked him
about you know his level of ability and
what happened to him
in his development he said the whole key
for me absolute key
was seven on seven football in the state
of texas
all through the spring it feels like
you're playing a big
game when you're in these seven on seven
games and he said
and that shows up not only in the
quarterbacks but the wide receivers
that we are throwing to all year round
are going to be great too so that just
puts an exclamation point on what you
just said let me say what
i talked to brian guticans the general
manager of the packers
and i said what if aaron rodgers is
great
what what what and he goes he said to me
that day he goes
hey listen what's the worst thing that
can happen
aaron rodgers plays great for the next
four years
and then we have a decision to make you
know with jordan love versus aaron
rodgers
he said but that would be great for the
packers those were his words
and i have to think if you see the guy's
words
and what he's really thinking is you
know
maybe we're motivating him too by
sticking it up his rear end
you know and i think maybe one day when
aaron rodgers
writes his book you know a long time
from now whenever it is
i want to read the eight pages
on this the last six months
you know and what exactly they have been
like
and what aaron rodgers really thought
that night
and how it translated into what he did
in the 2020 season
i want to read the first draft not the
final eight pages i want to read the
first 40 pages
on the last six months before it gets
edited
because that's going to be the stuff
that you don't want to miss and
peter they're not going to get four
years out of aaron rodgers if he's
playing like this because i think after
next season his message is going to be
you know what
i think i need to finish my career
somewhere else because look
there still isn't enough around him
there still isn't enough around him
for him to add to his legacy and win
another super bowl
all right kyle shanahan trying to add to
his legacy in san francisco
and you know to get back to a super bowl
and then win one
it's going to be hard to do either it's
going to be hard to even get to the
playoffs the way things have gone here's
some kyle shanahan from last night
after the 34-17 loss to the packers
we knew it was gonna be a challenge we
knew um you know at the start of the
week it was gonna be a challenge and
then
um losing those three guys uh yesterday
was obviously a bigger challenge but
um and i still thought we could have a
game and still thought we could play
better than we did tonight and um
you know being down like that and not
being at our best and going against a
good team like that usually that's
usually what happens but
i know we could have done better
yeah look hey if they would have had a
few more days i think kyle shanahan
could have come up with a game plan
and taught it to these guys who are
replacing the starters and maybe made it
more interesting and again they had an
opportunity to keep it close early it
just didn't work
and as you've said it was the san
francisco 49ers b team
that was out there what else did we
expect i feel bad for the 49ers but
that's why when you're up 10 points with
seven minutes left in the super bowl you
got to finish the job because there's no
guarantee you're gonna get back there
next year
whatever the reason whether it's
injuries whether it's a pandemic whether
it's you've got a huge target on your
back
and you're getting the best that every
team that you face has to offer peter
each and every week
this is another stark reminder of how
hard it is
especially when you've lost the super
bowl to go back to zero and zero
live as a marquee team in the nfl and
find your path
back to something close to the top of
the mountain and hopefully
for the team that lost the super bowl
win it the next time they
they try to get to the peak
here's the one thing i think i when i
think of the 49ers
i really think of and look i was
fortunate enough in 2017
the first draft that kyle shanahan
john lynch and the scouting director
adam peters had
in san francisco that i was able to sit
in and watch that draft unfold
and the one thing i learned that really
has stuck with me to this day
is and look every team is thorough i get
it
but what i really liked about what i saw
in the 49ers
is they were thorough but they were also
willing
to take risks okay and and look
i wrote a lot about a fourth-round draft
pick joe williams who ended up getting
cut
a year later that kyle shanahan wanted
badly
okay and he turned out to be a bust you
know
he was his desire wasn't there and all
that yeah you take it
who they draft in the fifth round that
year when everybody else was questioning
something about george kittle his
attitude his
production whatev whatever it was at
iowa
they get george kittle because kyle
shanahan felt
strongly coming out of that draft i'll
handle this guy i see
his physical tools and we're going to
get more out of them
and look and see what happened so i love
the fact that this team is willing
to be a risk-taking team this team is
willing to basically
say we're going to get enough of our
kind of players
and we have enough confidence because we
got a great personnel guy in adam peters
we have enough confidence that he's
going to keep bringing us
lower level down the road guiles guys
and to me one of the things that
surprised me last night really did
i thought jamichael hasty would play a
bigger role in this game
he only got four carries in the game and
look i you know who knows what the game
plan was and why it was
but that's the kind of player that you
see
doing well and rising up the ladder
even though he came from absolutely
nothing the 49ers take guys like that
develop them and help them win and look
the 49ers are going to win and they're
gonna win big they're not gonna win this
year
but they're gonna win and they're gonna
win big i don't know who the
quarterback's gonna be
i don't know how much longer richard
sherman is gonna be one of the best
corners in football i don't know that
all i know is that i have faith in them
to figure it out
i think back to that 2017 draft when
you're in the room peter if only reuben
foster had worked out
and if only if only they had decided to
take a risk on a quarterback named
patrick mahomes
just imagine where the 49ers would be
right now
right it's one thing to find those guys
in the late rounds but you got to take
care of the top rounds too
and man they had an opportunity to
exactly hear the bears we hear the bears
all the time get the short end of that
but man if patrick mahomes would have
landed in san francisco with kyle
shanahan you know why michael
mike you know why i believe that
happened
because i i will always think it was
nothing they said
but i will always think that they felt
they had kirk cousins in their back
pocket
you're absolutely right and they were
going to play one year
they were going to play one year with a
collection of
of beathards and and whoever's okay
they were going to play one year like
that and then they were gonna go get the
guy who kyle shanahan
really felt like he wanted to be his
franchise guy
for six or eight years it just didn't
work out that way and then
they were able to get garoppolo the rest
is history
but i mean look we could do a two-hour
show
on what the 49ers should do with their
quarterback position
uh going forward and we'd probably still
have some stuff to talk about at the end
but that is going to be an absolutely
interesting way and it look what has
become clear to me
is that you know nick mullins uh
you know and mullins and beathard are
you know they're placeholders but i
doubt that
anybody is gonna look at them and say
they're the answer now i feel bad for
mullins last night
the left side of the line was caved in
the entire
night he really didn't have a great
chance but he made some really dumb
decisions
like on just throwing a ball in the air
in a panicky way
when he's getting pancaked early on
handing the ball to the packers
and a short field that's a real good
idea by the way when you're playing
aaron rodgers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports